here is a video of NYU students removing
posters featuring missing
Israelis like think of the gall of this
I care about this I care about this
because I do care about Israel but
actually it's mostly because I care
about America and I care about freedom
and these battles these are no longer
local geopolitical battles these are
these are the battles of our time right
they they are and they're worldwide
anyway it's not just the students that's
the point of all of this it is coming
from The Faculty it is coming from the
administration uh here is an image of
University of Michigan Professor his
name is Eric Gordon we should all get to
know this guy I'm sure he'd have a
lovely life in Hamas um here he is
tearing down posters of kidnapped
Israelis some of them US citizens being
held in Gaza